hello my name is kurt busch
and i'm co-founder and ceo of sentient
we started sentient to build a new type
of processor to make
ai truly pervasive along with
specialized silicon
we developed an artificial intelligence
training pipeline
as well as a data platform that has
allowed us to ship over 10 million units
that are being deployed today in things
as small as earbuds
to as large as automobiles
[Music]
when we started sentient in 2017 we had
this idea for a processor architecture
that could bring
200 times the efficiency 20 times the
performance
and at half the cost of existing edge
processors
now the device can run multiple types of
applications but we were looking for
a single application to go to market
first that would have a significant
societal impact one day i saw my
youngest son
talk to his ipad and i said what are you
doing
he says i'm texting my friends and you
know my response
was was pretty clear is that said vinnie
you can't read
and you certainly can't type so what are
you doing because well i just talked to
it
that's when the light bulb went off and
i called up my co-founders and i said
let's make
voice the interface of the future
and after thinking about user interfaces
for a while we saw that the first
interface to the computer was the
keyboard
and with ms-dos that shipped at about
150 million units a year
the next was the mouse and with windows
that ships at about 500 million units a
year
and in each step it gets easier the next
interface which we all carry with us
is the touch screen and that's in the
smartphone and that's about a billion
five units a year
so we think that voice will be the next
generation interface
and the volumes could be 3x or even more
than what we see today
in the smartphone our processors are
currently used in applications from
event detection such as glass
breaking or fall detection wake words
command words speaker id
the devices can support multiple
applications running in parallel an
extremely small
power footprint so you could have a wake
word plus command word plus speaker id
say is it curt is it not curt and these
types of applications
can be deployed to enable ai and voice
interfaces without an always-on cloud
connection and coming soon we'll be
bringing a full speech interface
that can make speech truly a first-class
way of interacting with just about any
device
speech is not just a natural interface
for people but it requires no
training whatsoever when we first saw
that voice
was the next generation user interface
it was really enabled
by amazon and the amazon echo
if amazon hadn't come out with the echo
and put alexa devices
in everyone's home they really wouldn't
think of voice as the next generation
interface
so today according to unesco
approximately three quarters of a
billion people
are uncomfortable with reading and
writing and by adding a speech interface
to a low-cost cell phone
we can bring all of those people into
the digital age
and they can benefit from all of the
economic and educational advantages
that come with a digital connection
from earbuds to automobiles sentient is
making voice the next generation user
interface
[Music]
you